you know I'm too lazy to do the whole
like shark thing you know there's a
shorter thing to you I'll be eaten by
the shark
Hermione's okay can you come back
we saw the shallows recently yeah boy
what an experience yeah film was I had a
great time watching that film John humph
man how'd you feel thoroughly enjoyed
the shallows I mean like this is a lot
more than I thought it was what kind of
being what I expected it yeah it's a
straightforward survival you know kind
of tense horror movie throw some extra
things in there and make you go oh I
gotta agree with you there John with the
shallows I remember when I saw the
trailer I saw like the three freighters
they released and I remember thinking
like man who's like great cinematography
in here I love the environment Blake
Lively it looks like she's gonna give a
kick-ass stellar performance the film
delivers on that like because what got
me interested and watching this film was
when I heard little fun facts inside
sources Blake Lively's husband Ryan the
Reynolds his acting coach who worked
with him on the movie buried was Blake
Lively's acting coach on this film I
heard that I was like well Gary doesn't
be kind of similar in a way cuz you know
it's really like a one-man show for a
lot of it this one's like a one-woman
show and I think lake lively does an
amazing job in this phone I even cried
at one scene she had and I'm not ashamed
to say it as I heard other folks in the
theater crying to not you Tin Man I was
really impressed with her in this film I
mean I thought cry I cry ah no there was
a moment yeah there was a moment where I
got a little misty I don't think I cried
out right because Brock from yeah this
is a movie that really takes the time to
set up its main character and just let
you kind of get to know her and that's
yeah crucial to a movie like this props
to them for doing that and she helps to
sell that in a major way because there
are times when the script certain
conversations it's still a horror movie
so there are times in certain
conversations are a little convenient in
timing but she's always able to sell
them and make them feel genuine and make
me continue to care for this character
you know she's a lot of different things
the film was just a great experience mam
Lake Louise performance the films
awesome fear experience that crowd was
movie makes it interactive the movie
shifts through like several different
kind of genres throughout this shifting
kind of even at times when it might seem
like oh this is uneven or this is kind
of leftfielder this is weird I feel like
that always adds to the film it adds to
the the experience of what this
character is going on because the
moments the scenes are shot in terms of
how Blake Lively is feeling this
experience yeah all the stuff before the
shark shows up man that the shark stuff
there are so many times where the
audience you could hear them gasping you
know he's shifting around I was like
literally getting uncomfortable this
girl next to me who I don't know but she
is a kind woman
I guess my thing is I her wait no I
didn't met her afterwards when we did
the Facebook thing apparently she was
part of that oh I'm sorry
the whole time it was just really tense
again nerve-wracking and then what I
like to was it did more than just create
a cool script of a fun back and forth of
Blake Lively takes on the shard it
expands longer than I thought it would
and they had a lot of moments where it's
like just about survival without even
really the shark you know what I mean
there are times when the movie does kind
of break from being a survival movie and
it does become kind of like a really
focus well maybe horrible there are
times when it transcends and it gets a
little you know it gets big but I think
the movie earns those two because it's a
great balance of tension and build now
and then you know payoffs are or herbs
and stuff like that there are times when
it gets too big but by that time I'm
like we burned it we want to see this we
can't play out yeah exactly like we did
earn it it's it's a really well crafted
film like I love the directing from the
film but cinematography from cuz Sean
doesn't believe in me saying his
building well not only I felt like a
different martinas laviano
yeah just don't ever say Flavio Martina
well you're gonna face the difference
and here's first a little bit different
guy
mr. Firas first you know I'm right it I
never believed I know I'm right about
that if your name was Gregory Johnson
Alba and I just called you Gregory
Johnson like someone's gonna think of a
different dude I couldn't help but at
times sort of comparative gravity not
during the movie it's just when I look
back on the movie and I think of other
films that might be kind of similar to
this
well survival movies all have certain
parts and tropes that they cover in
territory well yeah I mean like well
gravity was this woman who's stranded
you know it's a survival game the big
difference that I felt with this and
gravity especially with the two
characters was Sandra votes me was more
like an avatar for us to experience it
you know like gravity's like a movie
theater experience
Blake Lively I really just gave a [ __ ]
ton about her you know I really got to
know this I felt like we were with this
woman and there's this amazing moment
that she has where she just where I'm
just like yeah she owns this film to me
it's like they define one of the
defining shots of the film I don't want
to give it away in terms of story and
stuff what happens is the the camera is
doing a slow panning on her once while
she's witnessing something horrible
happening we don't know what's going on
but so much of what the emotion is she
is conveying is felt we feel terrified
and horrified well we don't know what's
going on exactly that choice is kind of
masterful horror because it's like this
is you know it's a monster movie in a
way to be able to go you know pretty
much what's happening off screen but
we're only gonna show you the horror in
someone's face that makes it so much
more tense and engaging because that
it's terrifying just because you're
looking at the effect it hasn't somebody
else's generation that's I'm glad this
movie had a scene like that I don't know
I really credit Blake Lively for that
scene because she's using just her
imagination what's happening is not
really going on like it's just her
imagination just acting a lot of
different you know strange conditions
you know
she has to interact with people from
very far away at times like you know she
has to deal with you know the sharp
creature that's in effect you know so
there's a lot of you know like you said
reacting with things that aren't
necessarily there she's got bird friend
yeah you know and she managed to make
that natural like the thing is she
manages to take everything in this
script and make it feel natural I will
say and when the script isn't natural
because sometimes the script is a little
we gotta go here you know I feel like
the film was really wanted to make sure
on at a time like because I really feel
like that eighty minutes is like perfect
for this oh yeah yeah it's it's all you
need because and and the movie is smart
cuz it does take time to really get knee
deep in the survival aspects you know
like when these conditions are tough you
feel that too and the way they they edit
the water like whenever the camera
whenever the waves lap over the camera
they destroy the sound like they really
make you feel like you're in the ocean
things hurt like they hurt like yeah
feel all of this I mean she looks pretty
bad there's some way there's they
they're moments that take you into like
the experience of the horror yes she is
really like there's some great [ __ ]
oh I can't give it away but yeah her
first encounter with the shark is pretty
amazing well the way they use their
shark in this movie is great too because
you know this is a low-budget horror
movie so it's smart they really thought
when's the best time no no that's all
they made jaws as well like when's the
best time was the shirt and mechanic but
it cost too much problems yes so like
this one they have a a CG shark it looks
[ __ ] great yeah like it for the most
part it looks terrific
the way they incorporate the shark into
the movie is great because there's other
stuff going on this is a whole situation
it's not just Blake Lively versus sure
and they use it in great ways like they
props to them because it's again they
know how to handle a monster and what I
really want to say about Blake Lively
really fast is at first it is kind of
shot like when she's getting into the
water and stuff like oh she's so sexy
like a lot of this shot there's one shot
specifically we're panning up I'm pretty
sure it stops under present right here
and like leaves there I'm like you're
going to you
zip it the [ __ ] yes okay if you guys
want to know she does look sexy in the
bikini what I liked about it to us I
felt like as a choice of just like
primarily her in a bikini I wasn't
watching most of the movie going damn
she looks good like yes if anything it
makes her feel more vulnerable than more
exposed because she has nothing on her
but something to just cover up her body
a little bit you know that's sort of a
tough you know line the movie walks and
it is understandable you know like she's
just gone to the beach here a day she's
gonna go out and surf and stuff like
that like that's the situation you don't
wear oh but you know I could see how
like there are times when it is a little
bit like that's ooh bleep I think it's
intentional though because when they do
the ugly stuff it's at the right moments
it's before the shark primarily ever
shows up I like how the directors kind
of [ __ ] with you he's like yeah
there's the kind of film it is yeah
because that's how I felt about the
genre ships
oh yeah one's gonna be but not the world
she's that's not the world that she's
living in right now she's about to
experience something different it is the
world of the surf video that is like
okay I can actually see that the editing
in the direction are both very engaged
and you know some people might find that
overbearing I thought that was really
cool because to editing and the way they
shot it and the choices with you know
slow or fast motion like they all really
make this a tone painting you know yeah
well it's a manic one you know and a
desolate one tense movie man yeah it's
in it's okay to go bury gravity with one
last time with gravity I remember
feeling like well Sandra looks going to
be okay for most of this I mean this is
gonna be you know like like what a
90-minute film we got a she's gonna star
of the film she's gonna be fine but when
I saw this that never happened the
moments were so real that you just did
even if you were like well it's not
gonna die here you're still like you
still like how are you gonna get to the
next and then you're gonna might be
painful what she has to do you know
again it's a survival movie there's a
lot of painfulness in it but you know I
think ultimately that's what it comes
down she's like this movie is like it's
a kind of B survive like a b-movie
spirited survival movie this
really focused and really well-crafted
really energetic and it gives you time
to care about everything's you know it
may not be overly deep but it's the
showers like it's awesome like it's I
think they really did a great job with
what they had and they were able to get
a lot of talented people to elevate
everything there are a lot of great
scenes in this movie they're a lot like
memorable moments that you want to talk
about but you but it's a short journey
you know yeah it's so like I wouldn't
want to give anything away I think it
plays best in the theater when you can
really feel the tension you know and I'm
like I like feeling it with it with a
crowd where you're like yeah it's a
feeling it's a shared experience like
it's an experienced movie yeah does a
lot of things really what gives you
stuff to care about there's a moments of
applause where you're like yeah yeah you
know breaks free and kind of goes nuts
and you're like yeah yeah and it's that
little teaspoon of the b-movie that may
be just right for now that spirit is
around right now and delivering that but
in the tone of this movie is really cool
you know so yeah what is Jesus you've
been through a whole experience by the
end of this it's great
I don't have too many subscription
services I'll tell you one that I have
the real rejects YouTube channel that's
right it's one of you become a
subscriber today we have many things on
here trailer reaction reviews movie
reviews YouTube video reaction reviews
you got shits on some sketches and
whatever videos of reaction reviews that
Jonathan is in a playlist called reasons
Gary and you know what we're so kind
here we're not just gonna talk about the
real rejects facebook.com slash Blue
House
Jon's the social media manager of that
site but the real rejects did not
benefit
this panel this is just for that a kind
eat stay classy San Diego